qui à paulo les lits correspondant
italien en france de l' agence de presse
en deçà bonsoir paulo les lits merci
d'être avec nous sur rt france on a
entendu un les nouveaux chiffres 1 ce
soir en italie 6 ans elle 60 de nouveau
à mort en 24 heures et 8165 victimes au
total votre réaction quand à ces
chiffres
c'est une hécatombe hélas on est on est
face à une hécatombe qui aujourd'hui
frappe l'italie c'est une guerre
invisible contre un ennemi invisible et
malheureusement c'est le moment j'espère
le plus dur en tout cas parce que il
avait promis qu'à la fin du mois de mars
on on aura environ 1,6 traduisant un
reflux et on l'attend ce reflux il faut
avoir confiance le confinement il a
commencé le 8 mars et aujourd'hui il ya
plein de deux cac est qui qui qui
remontent disent on a un période qui
précédait le confinement est qui et qui
tombe malade après l'autre et
malheureusement les hôpitaux sont
débordés on l'a vu et on peut pas faire
face voilà à toute heure à toutes les
requêtes c'est une situation dramatique
on a vu l'italie aussi aujourd'hui à
bruxelles est là elle a battu le prend
sur la table parce que disons l'aide
pour l'instant elle est jugée
insuffisante l'aide européenne et jugées
insuffisantes par le premier ministre
giuseppe compte et donc voilà rien à
faire pour l'instant
espérons que cette crise vraiment puisse
être l'occasion de donner vraiment
preuve d'une nouvelle solidarité et
fraternité je dirais même entre entre
pays européens parce que si on le fait
pas maintenant le fera plus jamais de
corte
la situation est très très dramatique en
italie et c'est une situation qui le
conseille la chose importante c'est la
comprendre c'est que
en fait nous on est juste avant leur
arrivée avant les autres c'est à dire
que par exemple par rapport à ce qui se
passe en france on a juste 10 11 jours
d'avancé par rapport à toutes les a
toutes les événements qui se sont
produits ensuite en france donc la
france a une occasion extraordinaire
aujourd'hui c'est celle de regarder
l'italie prendre ce qu'ils devront et
des faits et écarter les ce que de
mauvais a été fait et je pense que tous
les autres pays aussi parce qu'on est un
petit peu dans dans cette terrible
épreuve qu'est le gros navires us on est
un petit peu un cobaye en tout cas dans
en europe et dans cette partie du monde
la russie aussi je pense que qu'elle
peut regarder en italie parce qu'elle
est vraiment une bonne conseillère
il voit donc face les doigts il faut
absolument pas désespérer il faut rester
positif encourageant et surtout rester
unie unis ni parce que c'est la seule
façon de pulvériser écrasé ce virus une
fois porte pour tout j'en suis persuadé
restez positifs rester unis mme quel est
l'état d'esprit en tout cas aujourd'hui
des des italiens son tour sont ils
toujours résigne en résiliant mais même
très très fatigué ça commence vraiment à
la on rentre dans la dans la troisième
semaine presque un mois de confinement
moi je parle avec ma famille sont en
forme et sont tous séparés
ma mère est seul dans cette maison
complètement déserte elle a 75 ans elle
se penche par la fenêtre elle voit
personne c c'est vraiment une situation
que qu'on peut vivre peut-être pendant 3
à 4 jours etc
mais quand ça rentre vraiment dans la
durée comme ça ça peut avoir même des
effets psychologiques très très dur on
n'est pas habitué donc il faut tenir bon
il faut se dire que avoir après l'été en
tout cas quelque chose va basculer mais
mais maintenant c'est vraiment quelque
chose de très très dur à vivre
je fais toujours l'exemple de la
deuxième guerre mondiale j'avais mes
grands parents qui me racontait toujours
du couvre-feu pendant la deuxième guerre
mondiale et me racontait que que il
descendait les ondes
dans les bunkers sous terre seulement 2
3 fois par jour c'est à dire quand y
consommer la sirène il y avait la larme
et on savait qu'il y avait les avions
ennemis qui arrivent et bombardés donc
c'était un confinement qui était au fond
limité 2 3 fois par jour et le reste de
la journée on sortait on faisait des
courses et là on a un confinement qui
dure 24 heures sur 24 donc c'est un truc
vraiment incroyable certes mieux
toujours mieux qu'une guerre parce que
au moins c'est pas des hommes qui
seraient entretenus entre eux donc c'est
pas quelque chose de fratricide mais en
tout cas c'est très très très dur à
vivre est cet ennemi invisible sous
certains aspects est même pire
alors lady dans ce cauchemar que vit
actuellement l'italie même l'ensemble du
monde
il ya une bonne nouvelle quand même chez
vous à rimini à rimini par bonds
puisqu'arras centenaire a été testé
positif aux copies de 19
il a été guéri il a pu rentrer chez lui
comment les italiens réagissent à cette
nouvelle mais avec une lueur d'espoir
heureusement qu'il y avait chaque jour
il ya de très bonnes nouvelles sont
annoncées même si elle passe un petit
peu parfois inaperçus par rapport à ces
bilan tragique des morts mais c'est ce
qui qui nous tient debout et qu'ils
n'ont fait pas désespérer effet nous
dire que voilà il faut aller de l'avant
il faut surtout garder optimisme et
c'est aussi une occasion peut-être ce
confinement
voilà de réfléchir peut-être aussi à une
nouvelle société à nouveau avenir commun
pour nous tous
peut-être sous d'autres critères et
voilà plus de solidarité surtout merci
beaucoup pour donner vie d'avoir répondu
à nos questions ce soir sur arte france
rappelle que vous êtes correspondants
italiens en france de l'agent
se pressent en deçà merci beaucoup